.
>> IT IS NOT.
>> WHO DOESN'T LOVE THE WEATHER
GIRL?
>> PERHAPS DAUNTED BY GUTTFELD'S
DETERIORATING RATINGS, LATE
NIGHT HOSTS TEAMING UP TO DEMAND
ACTION ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> EIGHT LATE SHOWS INCLUDING
THIS ONE ARE DOING CLIMATE
THEMED NIGHTS.
CRISIS SOLVED.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> WILD FIRES IN THE WEST,
FREEZING COLD IN TEXAS.
BILLY JOEL'S GOING TO HAVE TO
HAVE AN UPDATE FOR 2021 AND SAY
WE DID START THE FIRE.
>> IMMIGRATION, GUN VIOLENCE.
HERE'S THE THING.
WE DON'T ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
NONE OF THOSE ISSUES WILL MATTER
AT ALL.
>> THANKS TO CLIMATE CHANGE,
WE'RE LOOKING AT A FUTURE OF NO
SEX AND TONS OF VIOLENCE.
>> I DIDN'T GET THAT ONE.
WHO DO YOU THINK THEY'RE TRYING
TO CONVINCE?
>> THEY'RE TRYING TO CONVINCE I
GUESS HOLLYWOOD --
>> ADVERTISERS.
>> SO THEY DON'T LOSE THEIR JOB.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT PICTURE
ALTOGETHER, THEY LOOK LIKE A
CLASS OF DISNEYLAND LIVE
PERFORMERS ABOUT TO DO A LIVE
PLAY ON PLANET EARTH.
RIGHT?
LIKE A CHILD'S TV SHOW THAT IS
INSANELY NAUSEATING.
KIMMELL, WHO WANTS, RIGHT BEFORE
THEY'RE GOING TO BED, PEOPLE
LECTURING THEM ABOUT HOW THE
WORLD'S GOING TO END.
THIS IS LIKE A CULT.
THEY'VE REPLACED GEORGE CARLIN
WITH GEORGE SOROS.
>> ARE YOU MAD BECAUSE YOU ARE
NOT IN THAT PICTURE?
>> WHERE WOULD I STAND?
BEHIND THE SOLAR PANEL.
>> SOLAR PANEL MADE IN CHINA.
>> PROBABLY MADE IN CHINA.
>> YOU CAN'T DENY THE WORLD IS
HOTTER AND DRYER.
>> THE PEOPLE ARE HOTTER.
>> HOTTER AND DRYER BEFORE
HUMANS EXISTED ON THE PLANET.
YOU'VE HAD HOT PARTS OF THE
EARTH.
YOU'VE HAD OCEANS ON TOP THE
GRAND CANYON.
THE CLIMATE DOES CHANGE.
WHETHER YOU CAN TAKE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND THROW IT INTO SOME
FUND THEY ARE SUPPORTING AND
CHANGE THE TEMPERATURE OF THE
EARTH IS I THINK A VERY ARROGANT
PROPOSITION.
BUT GREG, I JUST LOVE TO BE
TERRIFIED ABOUT HOW I'M GOING TO
DIE RIGHT BEFORE I GO TO BED.
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
MATTERS.
WALK AROUND THE CITY AND PICK UP
MASKS PEOPLE HAVE THROWN AWAY.
I SAW A PICTURE FROM TETON
FOREST AND SAW A GRIZZLY BEAR
WALKING AROUND WITH A MASK.
>> FAKE BEAR.
>> ATE THE HIKER WHO WAS INSIDE.
WE HAVE SEEN CLIMATE CHANGE GO
FROM SPECULATION, DANA, TO
ABSOLUTE FACT IN THE MINDS OF
PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR POLITICS
RATHER THAN SCIENCE.
I FIND THAT ALARMING.
>> I DO THINK IN SOME WAYS THEY
ARE PREACHING TO PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY BELIEVE.
I THINK ONE OF THE FRUSTRATING
THINGS IS YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT
REAL SOLUTIONS.
ONE OF THOSE THINGS, IT TAKES --
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF ONE HOUR
OF TELEVISION IS MORE THAN TWO
RESIDENTIAL FAMILIES.
THERE ARE TRADEOFFS AND BACK AND
FORTHS.
THERE ARE GREAT INNOVATIONS
HAPPENING.
GREAT STUFF ON BATTERY
TECHNOLOGY.
REALLY GOOD STUFF ON CARBON
CAPTURE.
THAT KIND OF INNOVATION IS
WHAT'S GOING TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM NOT TELLING PEOPLE TO
NOT DO ANYTHING.
AND WHAT'S THE OTHER ONE?
>> GEO THERMAL?
>> FUSION.
NOT FUSION, GPS.
THERE'S A LOT OF INNOVATION IN
THAT.
>> WHEN YOU SEE COMEDIANS, DO
YOU THINK -- PERFORMER, SHOW
BUSINESS PERSONALITIES, CAN THEY
MOVE THE NEEDLE?
>> THEY USED TO.
CARSON USED TO GET 9 MILLION A
NIGHT.
>> THAT'S NOT THE NEEDLE.
>> COLBERT IS ONLY GETTING 2
MILLION A NIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT INFLUENTIAL.
THEY'RE TOO PARTISAN.
THE OLD GUYS WEREN'T THAT
PARTISAN AND PEOPLE WERE
INFLUENCED BY THEM.
REMEMBER THAT, GERALDO?
>> I WAS ON THEM.
>> OF COURSE YOU WERE.
JERRY LEWIS.
THEY USED TO PUT PICTURES UP OF
FAMINE, STARVATION, EARTHQUAKES
AND IT USED TO BRING TEARS TO
PEOPLE'S EYES AND THEY WOULD
DONATE.
IS CLIMATE THAT TYPE OF MEDIA
THREAT?
WAVES GOING OVER THE DUNES IN
NANTUCKET AND GET SOMEONE'S ES
SKATE DAMP?
THERE'S REAL STUFF LIKE
FENTANYL.
>> CHINA.
THEY WOULD BE BETTER SERVED
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT